una larga fila de camiones en medio de
la autopista señal de otro día de
huelgas en Reino Unido el jueves los
agentes de seguridad Vial detuvieron su
trabajo en Londres y el sur de
Inglaterra hasta el domingo lo que
obligó al cierre de varios carriles una
protesta más en una semana caótica el
martes miles de enfermeras salieron a
las calles El miércoles fue el turno de
los trabajadores de ambulancia
acompañados de los paramédicos que
manifestaron también su descontento no
tenemos otra alternativa nuestros
salarios son malos y los servicios del
nhs el servicio nacional de salud se
están deteriorando el gobierno se niega
a participar en negociaciones salariales
cuando Ese es el centro de nuestros
problemas ante un clima social muy tenso
el gobierno denunció la acción sindical
al llevar a cabo esta huelga los
sindicatos ejercen la máxima presión
sobre el nhs
y haciendo esto la cobertura de salud
está en riesgo especialmente en
situaciones de emergencia
pero los líderes sindicales aseguran que
los trabajadores de ambulancia continúan
tratando casos graves y devuelven la
responsabilidad al gobierno
cada vez que habla el secretario de
salud me llevo las manos a la cabeza
nunca había visto tampoco el liderazgo
de parte de y el secretario de salud
las huelgas podrían prolongarse a los
próximos días los trabajadores
ferroviarios se sumarán a los reclamos
también en Nochebuena